[Musique]
bonjour luc tu as une question à poser à
matthew et enfin peut-être un truc à
dire on joue parce que toi tu es
vraiment est un pilier de l'émission
dont je pars appuyé ici je pense et je
pense très sincèrement et je vous assure
que c'est vrai vous me faites là le
plaisir de vous inviter à votre table
pendant depuis sept ans mais la seule
personne à 10 maps et vous savez vous
qui a invité les gens qui sont cons ces
tables on discute pas c'est pas nous de
choisir qui est au tour de table ou pas
moi j'ai été un peu surpris par un
partout au départ pourquoi parce que moi
c'est ce qui m'embête c'est quand
notamment tu as fait une déclaration au
parisien te disais la bande des témoins
unis tout ça je te suis pas là dessus
parce que simplement il faut savoir que
je respecte le moment où tu as été mal
et tout mais par contre il faut pas
isoler sa faux pas et égocentré on a
tous été mal dans le sens où on est tous
été atteints par les polémiques est tout
simplement au contraire la bande était
ultra unis et on était vraiment tous
ensemble et tout est à ce moment là tu
nous as manqué vraiment parce qu'on a
voulu être un peu plus tous ensemble à
ce moment là j'ai moi j'ai s'amincit peu
baissé surtout comme après tu dis que la
bande est témoin unis ce n'était pas le
cas
et justement il ya des gens dont je fais
pas parti quitte on envoie des messages
cet appareil vendu donc c'est très
difficile aussi de t&d de hausse
illicite était mal un faux pas aussi je
veux pas que tu sois juste victimes et
nous assène insensible à aucun moment
quelqu'un plus géraldine vient de dire
je suis pas d'accord avec toi qui avait
une forme de lâcheté jeu là je reconnais
pas dans ce même tu dis c'est un mot que
j'utilise comme ça pour moi c'est pas de
l'acheter déjà pour déjà pour nous
autres est simple c'est que on dit pas
la même chose pour différentes raisons
c'est que pendant cette polémique à
l'époque je suis entre guillemets le
seul qui était particulièrement touché
dans une polémique puisque je vous ai je
n'essaye j'adore
ça parce que et que ça veut dire que il
faut pas faire moi je veux lutter contre
ça ces gens tu fais partie d'une
communauté donc tu te sens concerné non
au contraire je me console évidemment ça
veut dire que si on va attaquer les
asiatiques je souhaite conserver ici
alors moi aussi concerné par le canton
parisien est content que j'ai rapidement
est ce que j'ai dit dans le parisien
alors j'ai pas ni pour tous mangé mon
ressenti à moi mon ressenti à moi j'en
ai parlé avec gilles jamain passant que
sur la fin et ben maimon inimitié avec
gisèle commencé à recevoir et envoyer
que c'était plus joué avec avec benjamin
c'était compliqué aussi
voilà la vérité aussi c'est que tout ce
ton qu'on est pour des raisons
différentes des raisons personnelles
on a tous eu des problèmes l'année
dernière et c'était compliqué et je
comprends et je respecte ça vraiment si
si tu étais mal jamais je dirais quoi
que ce soit par contre qu'en syrie dit
on comprend les parties vous imaginez si
tous les chroniqueurs bassin seul coup
s'en aller parce qu'ils étaient mal au
même moment alors moi jouer les régions
si je peux rester avec kelly simple bon
sens fous de mon avis parce que c'est
pas de l'esma d'eau qui décideront de ré
et moi je vais être très honnête moins
mature et prêt à céder sur un moment
avec lui dans l'émission j'ai très
brillant mais plein de fois là il
revient et c'est comme des retrouvailles
après une rupture qu'on n'a pas décidé
en plus donc il faut construire
apprivoise tout je pensais bien se
passer donc y'a pas de souci maintenant
je dois dire comme je l'attendais pas ce
que je pense vraiment que personne
indispensable à part vous dans ce type
d'accord est une famille et même les
téléspectateurs
voilà la famille grandit chaque année
est vraiment je vous dis on vous dit où
vous êtes notre famille on se comporte à
l'antenne comme on est dans les
coulisses et chaque personne ne pourra
dire le contraire